give me your top three draft picks
on presidential candidates that are the
most qualified to fight against the
establishment and have a fighting chance
of winning or maybe making progress
purely draft pick who would some of
those names be for you
I think it's too soon to tell that's not
too sure I think you're dodging the
question a little bit I think a little
bit but but I am mostly because then
somebody's going to say well I'm
endorsing candidates
then forget about forget about top three
don't rank them okay give names and you
don't have to give them an order okay
you know what I'm saying and I'm being
and I'm being serious with what I mean
I'm not looking for an endorsement I
know you're not but that's how these
things will be interpreted but but but
if you look at it right now like okay
let's just we will read the scientists a
week ago at the governor's mansion 10 15
of us spend five hours together with you
know himself Casey you know others and
watching to see how he is behind closed
doors and you know what messaging and
all this stuff is being given we've
already publicly announced we'll do a
fundraiser at the house for uh for Biden
for Trump for DeSantis come do a
fundraiser we'll bring top 20 of the
biggest influencers we would gladly
bring Bobby into Bobby we're talking
right now about doing a podcast with him
I think June 28th we're doing a live uh
podcast with a couple hundred people
with vivec I would love to get a
Marianne Williamson to maybe debate him
and see what that setting will look like
because if they're not gonna we're gonna
get them 10 20 50 million eyeballs we'll
get the eyeballs so this is not a time
for these guys to play Big Shot thinking
those guys are not going to get the
eyeballs anymore but I'm sincerely
asking somebody that I believe you you
love America I firmly believe you love
America and I firmly believe a lot of
people
relate to you and I know the the the
um uh I've been around business for 20
some years I know how to dodge questions
professionally because you have to do
that when you're negotiating Etc et
cetera I'm not asking I'm not trying to
Corner you just give me
names and why like I think this per like
for example RFK here's why the santis
here's what whoever it would be what was
some of those things here's what I'll
tell you because you know Rhonda Santos
and I served together in Congress but
but to be quite honest I don't know him
very well so what I know of him is what
I have seen mostly publicly uh but I
haven't had a chance to to sit in the
room as you have to actually really get
to know him both as a person but also
really to get into some of the more
National issues to include foreign
policy that would inform my ability to
answer your question what I will say is
that people like Nikki Haley uh Mike
Pence uh Mike Pompeo
um
and Chris Christie uh we're seeing
Governor ASA Hutchinson
they are all part of the uh permanent
establishment uh machine uh whose
foreign policy would be very very uh
if not exactly the same mostly the same
as a Hillary Clinton Warhawk so those
those are the kinds of things that I I
have picked up on that I'm looking for
as these other candidates
um are out there and they're talking
about their positions on issues and and
unfortunately as is always the case I
mean you know
even though being commander-in-chief is
the president's most important and
foremost responsibility uh
the focus on what kinds of decisions
they would make as commander-in-chief
don't often come up in debates or in
forums and and a lot of these
presidential candidates don't don't
choose to talk about them so
um I'm hoping as you guys have your
forums that that's something and I that
you would that you would help shine a
light on because it is it is literally a
matter of life and death to know what
are the kinds of decisions these people
would make are they going to put us
closer to nuclear war with other
nuclear-armed countries or not because
that that the future of humanity is on
the line Tulsi I totally respect the
fact that if you haven't you know you're
not prepared to make any endorsements
and if you've never really sat down with
DeSantis and you know it's kind of hard
to acknowledge all that but at the same
time in 2020 you did share the stage
with a host of Democrats Bernie Biden
Amy Klobuchar Elizabeth Warren Andrew
Yang he's been on the platform before
Cory Booker Marianne Williamson Beto the
list goes on uh of all those names who
do you think you most closely align with
or would be a good leader how about that
I mean these are people you know sure uh
who did you get along with even on a
personal level who do you think would be
a good leader of that group
my answer today would probably be
different than it was back then largely
because with everything that we've gone
through since 20 like I feel like we've
almost lived a lifetime from 2020 until
now in 2012. it was this little thing
called code yeah
the the little thing called covid uh
frankly the the the proxy war with
Russia via Ukraine I mean a lot of
people's uh lack of Courage
unfortunately has been exposed
um you know the fact that not a single
Democrat not a single Democrat uh has
voted against you know remember that
first 40 billion dollar round of funding
to go uh that kind of brought in the
United States involvement in this war
against Russia not a single Democrat
voted against it I think there were
between the House and Senate something
like 60 or 70 Republicans uh who voted
against but not a single Democrat had
the courage to even just say let's not
rush into this let's actually think
about what are the second third fourth
order of consequences that could occur
once we we bring ourselves into this
what happens when we start to turn on
the tap at what point do we turn it off
the the progressive caucus in I think it
was November of last year if you
remember they sent this 30 members of
Congress sent a letter to Joe Biden
saying
please exercise diplomacy to negotiate
an end to this war because if it goes on
it will not only continue to create more
suffering and death for the people of
Ukraine but it increases the risk of
nuclear war it will increase
um the the negative impacts on our
economy on inflation on hunger and all
all of these things that are that are
facts that are very real costs of this
war they sent the letter one day within
24 hours they retracted it
they retracted it it was some
excuse like oh a staffer sent out a
letter uh without our approval which is
nonsense absolute nonsense we know what
happened they sent out a letter saying
how they actually felt and they got they
they they they got the hammer laid down
on them and unfortunately didn't have
the courage to say no
this is bigger than Party politics we as
Democrats they as democrats should have
the courage to call out your own
president and I would say the same thing
for Republicans so you know it is I have
been really disappointed on a foreign
policy perspective but also with you
know
men going into girls locker rooms and
exposing themselves all and this being
okay in the name of this trans ideology
and and and pervasive acceptance of
something that that is just
um dangerous and and fantasy this gender
ideology title like all of these things
that are so obvious in common sense that
most people see
they're they're I can't think of a
single elected Democrat in the house or
the Senate a lot of the names that
you've mentioned who've stood up and
just said you know what the kid says
right hey guys the emperor has no
clothes on let's just all admit that
it's not happening and it's and it's
really unfortunate and it's not
reflective of where I believe most
Democrats are in the country so none of
those names no one that you share to the
stage with
you would look back and be like that
person is actually qualified that person
is good they've all been dismissed from
class so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]